hundreds of VIP guests hundreds of
thousands of Spectators and a Global TV
audience of many millions the coronation
of King Charles III is a major
ceremonial and logistical challenge
nearly thirty thousand uniformed and
plainclothes police officers are on duty
in central London as well as security
and Intelligence Officers surveillance
cameras with facial recognition software
will scan the crowds our main focus
really is is to make sure that everyone
that comes into London for the
celebrations remain safely secure so
that's that's our absolute Focus but as
part of that as well is that we have an
extremely low tolerance for anything or
anyone who comes to disrupt this event
70 years since Queen Elizabeth was
crowned there Westminster Abbey is ready
for her sun and heir
rehearsals for the coronation procession
have been taking place in the dead of
night horses and carriages carefully
choreographed a Cavalcade of some 4 000
military personnel will escort the king
to and from Westminster Abbey and the
coordination needs to be meticulously
timed Britain's Global diplomatic
alliances mean the coronation guest list
includes heads of state and royalty from
around the world the leaders of
Australia and New Zealand and the Emir
of Qatar have been welcomed to London by
prime minister Rishi sunak at his
official residence in Downing Street
U.S President Joe Biden is represented
by his wife Jill
The Spectators have certainly come
prepared many equipped with bright wigs
and specially made costumes the most
Ardent and enthusiastic Royal fans began
pitching their tents along the
procession route days ago oh my God I'm
so excited I just I am did you see the
king went by about 20 minutes ago and he
was going there was somebody else in the
car with him it wasn't Camilla and he
was waving at us it was like oh my God
it's like really happening I'm happy to
be here with friends that I met here
during The Royal Wedding 12 years ago
and it's just exciting to be back in
London to celebrate the coronation the
dedication of the campers was
unexpectedly rewarded with a surprise
Royal Walkabout on Friday afternoon King
Charles shaking hands and accepting the
congratulations of the well-wishers the
next time these people see him he'll be
on his way to The Abbey the preparations
are almost over you can see the security
is in place and here on the mile the
crowds are already starting to build the
flags are up Central London a wash with
the red white and blue of the Union Jack
the only one thing that's not
predictable the Great British weather
there is some rain forecast for Saturday
morning Paul Brennan Al Jazeera The Mao
Central London